[Music]
hello guys and we are live
how are we this evening
i am doing well good to be back
good good good good as always
excellent well i'm being joined here by
spence from aliens and stuff and you go
find them on the internet they're
they're everywhere excellent channel go
subscribe and
uh resident american who's going to tell
us about tv show that means spencer
uh resident america
you're the only one we allow
especially
to be the only one allowed in the
country
so this evening i thought we would get
together we would have a little bit of a
chinwag um about
the streaming services that we're
getting at the moment
and how
there's a lot of stores going around at
the moment that that's streaming is
going to kill cinema
um and i personally love going to the
cinema i think it's it's awesome so
um i i don't want to see the death of
cinnamon but obviously thanks to kovid
they're having a bit of a problem anyway
so i just thought we'd have a little bit
of a chat and what do we think maybe
cinema's going to be like in 10 years or
where are we going to be in 10 years
time so shall we start off with the
black widow lawsuit because i think
that's an easy one to to get started on
anybody got an opinion on it before i
just roughly give a rundown of what
actually happened well i i
um
way back in the day i used to work in
film
and um
yeah i think uh
carl johanson really got screwed or yeah
because it's these contracts if you read
through um other uh stars contracts or
what's reported on him that was in the
marvel summer universe
hers was just really everyone else got
their their day in the sun everyone else
got their theatrical release and their
uh income was based on theatrical
numbers well if they you know kneecap
her
and just started on a streaming service
during a pandemic
well she's losing out tens of millions
of dollars
that is the thing is that with this with
the cut of the cinematic that contract
worked so well for people like robert
danny junior that contract was
you know he had a similar contract for
like iron man where he got a cut of the
the back end rather than a large fee to
begin with they didn't know
how successful it was going to be
and he i mean he's his children's
children children not going to have to
work
off the back of iron man his iron
grenade
yeah i mean
obviously it's uh it's it's sort of
contract stipulations isn't it um and i
i come across this quite a lot in my day
job sort of going through contract
agreements and trying to find where
where wording is is is designed a
certain way but
yeah i mean it's i i've seen a lot of
people online saying you know oh well
you know she
you sort of millionaire actor
complaining about this but you've got to
look at it and think well they kind of
set the bar there didn't they and then
through a complete technicality
it's well it's like storm was saying
it's it's it's gonna scrape the massive
amount of income off and yeah i can't
help but feel bad and it's kind of like
you said in the episode jamie where you
said you know this was meant to be
you know sort of your time to shine this
is your gift for having stuck with us
for all of these years and then it just
sort of left a bit of a bad taste in the
mouth at the end there i think
most definitely
you know one thing for for me was you
know at the beginning of all of this you
know the very first i think
was it iron man 2 was
hansen's first appearance
now she was promised you know we're
going to do you know your own you know
origin story your own black widow story
how long ago was iron man 2 and she's
been promised his promises you know thor
got his and
it's
all these other characters were shaping
up with spin-offs and whatnot and um
finally at the very end she's granted
her wish you know and uh
they screw her
i mean she they release her uh
her film that she worked very hard on
worked more than a decade for
and they waited till you know right in
the middle of a pandemic and they cut
her on the box office receipts by also
streaming on disney plus
it didn't actually have a bad first week
but it had the biggest second week
drop-off of any marvel film released so
far
um and i was have you seen some of the
videos about scarlett johansson's
physical preparation for all of these
movies oh my god
he put it through the ring no
absolutely
and they're just talking about you know
the millions of dollars whatever she
should have earned she earned it
yeah you know and she was one of the
most popular characters they disney have
earned an absolute fortune up here and
at least they could have done but
i mean about three months before the
film released um the film was finally
released because you know super putting
off and putting off obviously her
lawyers and her people realized this was
gonna this was a possibility
so they um they said well can we we want
to read and go through the contract and
disneyland nope
not doing it that's where everything
would give like
yeah they wouldn't even give like um
a compensation fee or anything yeah
you know was going to be uh released
online and he threw an absolute fit he
said no it goes to the theater first
and we're waiting on it for the the
theater uh top gun maverick
that was going to be released they said
no no because remember it was supposed
to be out right when i think mark um
it was supposed to be was it a christmas
film or a summer film i think it was
going to be a summer film originally in
2017
yeah and then they canceled that and
they got pushed off and pushed off and
pushed off because it's one of those
films that's
made for the cinema you know for a
theater large screen big loud speakers
popcorn
yeah but so it's not it's not like
go ahead i'm sorry that's sorry i said
like a lot most of these films are the
summer blockbusters the big action
movies they're always built they're
they're they're better at the cinema
aren't they
yeah why are we seeing more and more
big action blockbuster movies
not going to cinema
and going straight to netflix
amazon prime have started doing it now
um and obviously disney are going to be
doing it i mean a few examples old guard
with schliese thrawn last year
huge hit for disney for netflix sorry it
absolutely smashed it because everyone
was in the house
so i mean if they signed up a sequel
almost immediately chloe's throne is at
the top of her game you know she's not
like a husband on her way down you know
she's not like
i don't know
for some reason all i can think of is
drew barrymore but actually seems really
mean
to me um but you know she's not she's
not you know she's not a 20 years ago
actually she's you know
she can pick and choose her her roles
um
and there's examples
bright with will smith that was a big
budget movie it was a huge budget film
straight to netflix and that is a film
that i would have loved to sing in the
cinema you know but um
tomorrow war there's another title comes
you know i thought you know i first saw
it's like okay this is just what's on uh
streaming today let's go watch it holy
crap was that a good movie loved it
and i think before you know within three
days they approved a sequel you know the
director was uh previously an animated
filmmaker he's going well what do we do
next i mean they were so it was such a
good story but yeah straight you know
and
for me i don't think it's enough this is
this is my bigotry i i don't think it's
going to be a great movie if it hadn't
hit the theaters first
and apparently there's a lot of good
stuff coming straight to streaming
because you know back in the day it was
well it's straight to video so you know
how good could it be
but now that's no longer true just
because it's straight to video or
streaming doesn't have anything to do
with the quality
yeah i think that was the point i was
going to make creating i stole your
thunder i'm so sorry i'm american what
can i do
yeah you've been doing that to the
british for 200 years so what about um
but i was going to say like the i think
the example that we've got all the
comparison we've got spencer you're too
young for this you won't remember this
mate um but me and stormy will
is when videos became popular and the
the video shop became popular and they
said that was the death of cinema and to
be honest it nearly was
i know in the uk a lot of cinemas shut
and blockbusters was you know that was
friday night you went to blockbusters
and got your popcorn and your drinks and
yeah you know um is there a similarity
between that and what we're seeing now
but worse because the quality is better
spencer said in some two three minutes
go it's no i mean
it's hard isn't it because we we very
much live in a a culture of convenience
now don't we
you know everybody wants there there's a
an element of instant gratification
about anything and i mean i'm i'm guilty
of it everyone's guilty of it you know
we we expect it now you know nowadays
um i think that
as particularly with everything being
closed over covered i think people have
almost sort of forgotten the magic of
the cinema though do you know what i
mean so yeah i've watched a ton of um
i've been watching a ton of movies on on
netflix prime
whatever you know over the last 18
months
um and really sort of got into my cubby
hole with it and yeah i like i like
watching movies at home and i like that
you know if i want to see something new
i don't necessarily have to go out
um but a couple of weeks ago um first
time i've been to the cinema since the
pandemic but i went to see the new
and it's not
sidetracked but i went to see the new
candyman film because i'm a big big
horror buff um and
i was so conscious when i was in there
because i hadn't been for so long
the the the sound of uh of raindrops on
like a glass ceiling you know and and
you could you know you can really pick
the sound design out and it creates an
atmosphere that sort of sucks you in and
obviously you've got the lower light
levels the the big silver screen you
know i think there's there's something
magical about going to the cinema and i
think a lot of people
through um the convenience of sort of
you know direct-to-box releases have
kind of forgotten that you know or is
that just me
no i think you're up i think the example
i had was during um
the lockdown the cinema was still open
for a bit and we were still allowed to
go in the in-between but obviously
nobody was releasing films and you had
to sit two seats apart and we went to
you know one way system was a bit of a
nightmare and but we've got a beautiful
cinema by us and it's one of the odeon
looks cinemas so they've got rid of all
the old crappy seats you know like that
you're that close to the next person in
front of you and they're all these
recliner seats you just go ah yeah i
think you've got loads of feet room
um and then it's amazing so i went to
see jurassic park the original
oh and
and it still stands up you still the
cinema going i've watched this film how
many times in the tv and it doesn't wow
you i'm watching it in cinema now and
i'm like
god damn this is a good film
you know it's 20 years old and it still
looks amazing it still looks absolutely
beautiful
especially when like t-rex crushes the
ford explorer and just screams you know
right into the camera into the audience
even just the first time you see like
the diplodocus
you know the long neck ones when they
all go
and then it pans around and they'll say
even that you're just like
it just looked incredible um
it's not the same effect
a tv i don't care how big you tell
yourself
it's not the same
um
i'm just worried that we're going to
have a whole generation of people that
don't appreciate
that it isn't the same
and that oh i think i can pause and go
for a wii
well yeah you can but is is that really
i can watch the football on the tv i
still quite like going to old trafford
it's you know
well it's kind of like just because we
have the capability to to watch these
things on a phone screen does that mean
that we should i know that um david
lynch was very very cool recently about
how
he doesn't want anybody watching his
movies on on mobile phones you know
because it's it's it ruins the
experience and it's it's like you were
saying storm about the the new dune
release you know and how and how hard
they thought to make sure that went out
in cinemas because that's how it's
designed to be experienced
um and i i guess yeah in a way you could
look at it and think you know if you are
if you are streaming stuff to your home
you know even if you've got a nice tv
are you really getting the most out of
that media you know
well it's like i don't think movie
theaters are going to go away i don't
think they're going to be like
blockbuster
because you know
you guys are you know you still have
stage plays
i'm sure somewhere in london someone's
doing macbeth right now and how old is
that [ __ ] i'm just saying you know we
still go to opera we still go to the
symphony we still go to the public we
actually it's not [ __ ] that's
shakespeare
what's up
i don't know look at him stephen king
macbeth send all the hate mail to
spencer he loves getting his hate mail
no but i i don't think the the theater
experience is going to go away because
it's just something you can't get at
home you can't get a live stage play
like something like macbeth at home or
uh opera or a musical it just
you can see it on tv but
you know if you if it's like um
you know if you go see you know
the balshoy ballet
in person it's a completely different
experience than seeing it on uh
tv
you know
and i don't think it's gonna go away i
think you're gonna see there will be
movies
and we've already seen it already seen
this trim there'll be movies made for
the cinematic experience
and then there'll be stuff made for
tv screens you know or video screens
like and we've been doing that for what
60 70 years with soap operas and just tv
shows you know it's made for that small
medium and they're still impactful
you say that though a lot of theaters
have closed
in the uk a lot of theaters are now um
weatherspoon pubs
um you know so unfortunately and the
ones that are open a lot of them rely on
quite a lot of um income from the
government you know they get the you
know we've got the arts council
right now they've really really
struggled through the pandemic and a lot
haven't properly reopened yet
you know obviously we've got the west
end which does well and then most towns
have like one or two theaters but they
rely on other income as well they rely
on being you know having like business
stuff in the week and
you know
yeah yeah that sort of thing cinemas
can't do that
well i mean cinemas get government help
if they graduate struggling in in
america you know actual theaters cinemas
they can't stay open on just ticket
sales it's um
most of their money a huge portion of
their money is made on concessions
popcorn snacks drinks that's where most
of the money comes from the movie is
just to get you to the to the building
to get you to buy popcorn you know and
we have like a half hour of ads to buy
the popcorn and drinks before the movie
starts literally
let's go i don't know how to go let's go
just a little little little dots and
cupcakes and bags and popcorn
but some half a
coke in a smile
yeah and that shows that cost 15 pounds
like
what the hell is this
gold nachos are they going to do a
little dance for me
what the hell do these cost this much
money
but yeah yeah i think
in the future you know
uh i still think movies are always going
to be more popular than stage plays or
musicals or
the ballet or the opera whatever
but it's still going to be i think a
specialty entertainment in the future
and i think the pandemic has just
accelerated it
you know
yeah i mean we saw in the uk we've
already seen one large cinema chain
struggle uh cineworld over in the uk
nearly went under they they closed the
one actually in my town had shut
and the big ones managed to stay open
but i think they went down to about 30
semes where they had 100 and something
wow and the odeon is obviously that big
chain cinema here i think it's in the u
it's in the us the odion
actually might have even started in the
us
i'm not sure but um but that's the big
chain over here as well and that's just
about managed to to stay alive sort of
thing but god knows what their debt is
like now but um
because they would they said they've
been spending this a large amount of
money but it's almost like they've been
preparing for them they've cut seats out
of the cinemas they've halved the number
of seats
but they've made the seats amazing
and really really comfortable it's
almost like they've they saw a head sort
of thing we're going okay
bums and seats isn't going to be the
thing the way to do it anymore it is
going to be the concessions like you
said stormy they do they do really well
over here they do um
like a monthly thing so i actually play
a direct debit monthly
um and i get to go to to the cinema so
as many times to like and it's a little
bit more than a cinema ticket a month
but that goes every month and they
really really push that as well and i do
wonder how many people pay that like
going to the gym you know your gym
membership
a lot of the um the cinemas down down by
my way uh are independents um or like
very small chains so there's only like
four or five of them you know real sort
of sort of smaller um chains but um
i think the the probably the most
successful one local to me they
basically built on a bar restaurant as
as like you know an aside to the cinema
really really great cinema as well in a
great quality seats um you know good
good sounds good screen um but what
they've started doing is sort of
kind of
sort of make it like a night out so
they'll have like dine and movie where
it's like a special deal where you can
come in have a proper meal like an
italian food and then go on all like you
know you get drinks after and they do
the same um
direct debit system that you were
discussing jay so that you can you know
go and see a set amount and then you get
a discount on concessions and things
like that so i think some of them are
and that's probably i'd say the most
successful cinema locally and it's
because they've kind of diversified and
tried to make it a little bit different
different but it's like you said you
know some of the other ones i know
around here are struggling a bit i mean
when i went to the cinema the other day
there was
me and five other people
and it was just empty seats as far as
the eyes could see and i was thinking
geez you know think about the
electricity bill here you know
you know
i i saw shangchi
yesterday
i did a video on it and called it shang
glee all the way through
every single bloody time
oh that was painful when i was editing
it i realized
did you just do it
every time
yeah i know i just have to comment on
going yes i know
was it busy when you went
yeah i was gonna say it was about half
full it was saturday at three o'clock in
the afternoon when it was it was a good
show but that like say our cinema has
actually bounced back really well on the
way out the
the lobby area was pretty much full of
people
um there's it's a big multiplex 10
screen sort of thing um wow
and but they've just had this massive
refit about six months before code hit
they must have been so gutted when that
happened like oh
look at all this lovely investment we've
done
sort of thing
that'll pay for itself in no time
well yeah exactly
um all right so
we've sort of said we don't think the
cinema is going to go away do we think
it's going to have to do like what we've
said there but it's going to have to
become a night out then so the ones that
survive are going to be restaurants
things they're going to be part of a
multi you know because i mean our other
cinema the one in cineworld is actually
part of
that there's about 10 restaurants
it's it's off the town center
um it you know there's lots of things on
this little hotel there and everything
else um but that's the one that should
um
but it's part of the night out
experience is my point those are the
ones that are going to do okay but do
you think we're going to lose
a lot of you talking about those
independent ones spence do you really
think they're still going to be there in
five years
oh
i don't know i think
as long as people keep
pushing
to to get stuff released in cinemas as
opposed to um you know direct to home
then
there's always going to be something
that you can't
see without going out you know
so i suppose as long as people people
keep pushing that i mean if it does get
to a point where every single major
studio goes that's screw it we're going
to release it simultaneously i think
that's when they'll be a problem because
at that point you know you
there it's not like there is no other
option other than to go to the cinema so
i think as long as as long as there's
that degree of separation you know then
it should be fine but then who knows i
mean obviously there's a lot of
there's a lot of people that maybe
wouldn't go to the cinema but would buy
it if it was released at home and i
imagine that you know there's probably
some corporate executive at the top of a
lot of these companies going oh it's an
opportunity here
you know
now there'll be somebody doing math
it's expensive to release the cinema at
the cinema i should imagine advertising
and blah blah blah yeah yeah
i think uh in the art house film houses
will always be a thing you know um
mostly just in you know really
metropolitan areas though i mean like it
is
it's a specialty kind of thing
um
but i agree it's going to have to the
the environment
uh the theater environment is going to
change gratefully greatly i remember the
best one i've ever been was the the
kabuki theater
uh owned by the sundance in san
francisco they had a michelin chef
preparing whatever you wanted with a wet
bar and they'd bring it to your seat
how spoiled i got so spoiled man every
sunday i was there it was just wonderful
you know popcorn's still stale what was
that it's popcorn okay oh the popcorn
was glorious you could get it with all
sorts of sprinkles and stuff you know
did you want the garlic butter did you
want some sort of truffles popcorn well
i was just in san francisco you know
i mean is a michelin chef for god's sake
serving you
theater snacks it was glorious
expensive but glory wow that's the key
isn't it
that's where they made the money
right i've took out a second mortgage
we're going to the cinema baby
i do i do wonder whether in five years i
think i think we'll see a lot of cinemas
close um because i just don't i think
just the money won't be there anymore
but i do think though that like i say
black widow was released simultaneously
shang chi wasn't so great was it just a
blip
was it just the disney plus thought
okay we've waited over a year now we've
got to get this damn film out and we're
going to do a disney plus release at the
same time because we want to push disney
plus and
you know people aren't going to the
bloody cinema yet it's a huge risk if we
release it it's a massive flop
you know nobody what nobody because
they're covered people are scared
so is it just
a one-off
yeah i mean i think there's def there's
definitely an element of that i think as
well though in in in not in defense of
marvel or disney but um
obviously they've always got a really
really tight um
release structure
planned you know they plan these things
out way and i mean we've seen with you
know infinity war and game they plan
these things out and i know they ran
into massive problems because not only
could you know were they struggling to
film and get all of that done but then
when they were actually completing
projects they were just like kind of
like black widow just sat there doing
nothing which meant that the next
release was held up which the next
release was held up and um if you look
at their um
phase three i think we're in phase three
now is that right or is have we just
finished playing through to five so
haven't they but yeah yeah i think if
you look at the the original release
window they've they've moved it around
so much stuff has come out before it
should have and things have switched
orders and things and when you think you
know particularly with the the disney
plus shows they're trying to tell this
coherent story which is which is plans
you know in stages to come out
um there must i'm sure there must have
come a point where it was like well look
if we don't release black widow now then
we can't release shang chi until this
time and then we're supposed to be
releasing these shows and that might not
have as much context if we release that
now so we might have to push that back
and so i i do think there might have
been an element of
of creative push to get it out just so
that the rest of the story could be told
maybe do you know what i mean maybe
disney doesn't want to compete with
itself
in similar shows yeah yeah
well you've also made the point that
they mentioned the tv shows as well
because a lot of the tv shows
explain
lots of what's coming in the movies you
know this whole multiverse thing with
the marvel
it's it's going to be very strongly
linked to scarlet witch tv show and they
must have been biting the bit together
they've got disney plus it's sat there
initially there wasn't a great deal of
content on it it wasn't i don't think
really it was until the fox sale went
through and they put the scarf on there
and then all of a sudden they've got all
the star stuff on there as well
yeah now it's decent now it competes
with netflix but at first
i had netflix i had um disney plus and
we watched a few films on it in the
first month and then we didn't look at
it for like nine months
and i was paying for it the whole time
so
and but but then you know um
that hit like i said and and and then
i'm just waiting for the marvel tv
series to start and they just weren't
they just and the disney executives must
have been doing their nuts
come on we've got this platform
nobody's watching it it's gonna it's
gonna collapse and you can imagine that
if the disney plus has collapsed because
just nobody was watching because they're
waiting on content well they put so much
stake into i mean obviously the
mandalorians like the first big thing
but they put they clearly put so much
stake into these marvel tv shows i mean
you know whatever you think about them
they're they're high budget affairs you
know they look they look like a marvel
movie you know
yeah you know the falcon of the winter
soldier looked like civil war you know
it was it was
cinematic quality
um so yeah i mean that's that's another
element that i guess is that they're
kind of new yeah
yeah i would say scarlet witch even more
there was a lot of effects in scarlet
witch a lot more than soldier i think
there was it was a very heavy effects
series and it was just as good i think
marvel had been doing that for a few
years though i remember watching
daredevil i've actually mentioned this
in a video i haven't released yet
the the first series of daredevil on
netflix
there's a fight scene
in it that he's walking down a corridor
and he's going to save a young boy
if you've seen it you'd remember it it's
phenomenal and it was the first time i
remember sitting there going
that's cinema standard that's
that's one of the greatest fight scenes
one of the greatest things about this
one the corridor one where people ended
up getting kicked in and out of rooms a
fair bit it was like one continuous shot
yeah that was a continuous shot reminded
me of um
oh you know oh boy the korean face
yeah so you know that one shot fight
sequence in the corridor but from the
side it yeah i got big vibes obviously
standard of yeah it really reminiscent
of like hong kong golden heart this type
moves from back in the day
and there's a lot of that with shanghai
actually i was watching a lot of
shanghai yesterday and i was just
thinking i just think back to like all
the classic jackie chan movies back in
the day when they were actually good
and um you know and crouching tiger
hidden dragon and stuff yeah
yeah there's a fight scene in shanghai
actually that's very similar that's on a
bus
and that's pretty much one shot but it's
it's builds
there's one bad guy then there's two
then you realize that half the bus are
actually waiting to kick his ass
something and um it's just it's just
phenomenally shot but that that shot and
daredevil blew me away that was one of
the first times i remember going wow
that's that's cinema standard and then
we start they've got shows like game of
thrones and things like that obviously
that yeah they took up to another level
again where you're like
that's not
tv anymore that's we have to almost
think of like
something else
that's that's beyond anything we've seen
on the television before
um
i'm watching on my little crappy 50-inch
tv going i need a bigger telly
oh my god this is amazing well you guys
keep using this term cinematic spencer
started it first of course i blame since
spencer then and jamie you started it
but you keep referring to this you know
this film was so cinematic you refer to
you know sin the the state of what the
impact the emotional impact of watching
something on a big screen
and
you know you started off with scarlet
witch talking about how it was cinematic
you know and uh winter soldier and
falconer soldier how was cinematic
i think filmmakers
are
getting to the point in terms of skill
and talent
that they are making things for the
small screen and the big screen at the
same time and it just
they're just making quality films that
is emotionally impactful like for
um i don't know if you remember back in
the start the x-files days
their production schedule it was crazy
because they were shooting everything as
if it were a movie even though it's a an
hour episode
they were shooting it as a major motion
picture and that's why it had such an
eerie emotionally impactful uh
quality to it
and you know i think that's what
cinematic means you have that impact of
the moving image not necessarily this
big screen
but i think disney and especially
starting with man delorean like spencer
suggested
really brings the cinema the the
emotional impact of that big screen into
whatever space you're looking at whether
it's on your desktop computer your
widescreen at home
your little iphone whatever i think that
is that's becoming
a skill that filmmakers you know in
terms of the director of cinema or the
the director of photography the director
itself the the writers are all aiming
for
and one note on jackie chan have you
guys ever seen his movie 1911
no
of course you you have
uh jamie i'm sure have you
1911 i
it is not a kung fu movie it is about um
19 the uh the chinese war of 1911.
jackie chan is in it
he is excellent
if he just i mean he's a great this
shows that he's a great honest-to-god
actor and that he is being wasted on all
these silly kung fu movies
1911 i heart oops sorry i hardly
recommend it great film great great and
i saw it in one of those crazy little
tiny independent theaters is in san
francisco on a sunday while being fed
greatly by a missionary
is very good as well i mean i think the
um his singing really really took a
whole different level in the third album
and you know i'm joking i've been
listening but he is actually one of the
largest selling uh music artists in the
world
because people in china love him right
um
david hasselhoff in germany
number one yeah he's got more number
ones in germany i think i'm sure number
one elton john or something's ridiculous
statistic but anyway um
so what do you think we're going to be
like in 10 years then because obviously
the streaming network seems to be
getting and you have to tell us what
it's like in in america stormy but we've
basically got
three
big maybe four if you count sky
so we have sky who have sky cinema
um they release movies every couple
years and those movies are getting
better quality as well um their newest
ones uh karen gillan from um
uh guardians and doctor who obviously
spence you'll be a big fan of that amy
pond oh god she's so pretty
um
i have an opening for a doctor who is
that she's there on a naughty
policeman's outfit and that's how well
yes yeah god that was good but anyway um
she's in a gun gunpowder milkshaker that
is a big budget action move and it looks
freaking awesome but that's going to be
on sky cinema and in the cinemas at the
same time released at the same time
they've done that with quite a few other
films but up till now their films have
been
like straight to dvd movies that they've
not been the greatest quality but this
seems to be returning you know this is
this is again an actress top of the game
who's on the up
um becoming more and more popular and
and you know it's a big action budget
movie
larger names in it don't they
yeah yeah yeah exactly seems to be
getting more and more they seem to get
more confident and more and more putting
more and more money down there so
um and then obviously we've got the
netflix and um we've got uh amazon prime
and then um disney plus
we don't have hbo max and things like
that over here
who are you you don't have hulu
no no no we have disney plus um so
actually we're really happy mom because
orville
is now on disney
so i'm really happy about that
because i had to watch it on fox on
skype i'm like on that satellite tv and
it was on at like 11 o'clock at night on
a wednesday or something i get to forget
to take it but so i'm very happy at some
point i know disney plus
but what so what is it like over there
in
in america though stormy
what sort of cost is that how many these
channels are there over there
oh man um
well i'm an absolute slot for streaming
services
my big ones is like um i've got a hbo
i've got uh paramount plus because you
know star trek
um
disney plus because of star wars and
marvel
i've got hulu because i get it free
because that's because of the
subscription i have for my phone
um i've got a bunch of uh
i've got nebula and i've got curiosity
channel which are you know just
educational
huh no it's definitely an apple channel
right
right
and today the antelope will be in waking
season
as we watch the antelope ranch across
the savannas of africa yeah that's
that's probably not born you're thinking
yeah
uh but yeah there it seems like there's
another one that pops up every day and
they're
trying you know and these always oh
apple plus
of course
and i've got amc
because of you know walking dead
and all the other good content of amc uh
so but
it seems like when you have a new uh now
when you have a new streaming service
coming up
they always try to seat it with some
really big tentpole sci-fi something
another you know it's oh this so this
legion of fans will go out and buy it
for a year just so they can watch it and
but there's a surprising amount of free
streaming services that pop up
uh pluto tv
is really good
i mean you know i mean it's it's in its
older films that you know from the 80s
not older
from the 80s 90s and the
arts
um
there's also a minecraft channel on
pluto pluto's just kind of like live
streaming you know and it's really it's
it's a and it's it's mesmerizing you
know it's just nothing
where's the funding come from though is
there adverts or something yeah it's
advertising uh based that we know all a
classic who doctor who is on pluto
all the time see over in the uk we've
got
bricklocks for the classic who
yeah that's not on demand it's just
whatever
you know you just go and watch and
whatever is on that
oh
it's just like it's just like a tv
channel but online right yeah right it's
just yeah it's all programmed right and
there's another one called 2b which is a
lot of horror i think
um but yeah there's a lot of those
popping up that are really good good
content but it's advertising supported
which is like most tv is except that you
don't have to subscribe you don't have
to give them your email address or your
phone number and then you just sign up
watch it download and watch
i think that's where our future's going
at the moment i've got sky tv i get most
of my tv through a satellite
in five years i'm sure they're going to
come to us and just go yes to your
broadband now you don't need the
satellite addition anymore we'll take it
down
um something and that to be honest i
don't know why it is now
um we could we could easily watch it
through i watch all my netflix and
everything and then i switch over to my
satellite dish
why why don't they just stream it
through
but skye has now tv as well which is
like their streaming version i'm like
why are these the why are they still
bothering getting sky tv i don't
understand it we're so far behind
it seems a bit slow to us
um yeah so you've got obviously a lot
more than this and and i think the
internet channel likes what you're
talking about there i think that's
something that we'll be seeing over here
soon i get i get something called the
roku channel because my um right
i watch my thing through roku
um it's just the box but i watched my
internet and stuff through my smart box
on um and that's actually ever so often
something good will pop up on there i'm
like i'm bloody helping boston legal so
i'm watching boston that's fantastic
but most of it's rubbish but every so
often the new um uh
how the little comedian um chris oh
what's his name
chris hart no it's not chris hart is it
kevin hart
kevin yeah kevin hart but the new kevin
hart live show is on the roku channel
it's not anywhere else
really it's brand new it's a brand new
it's in this and this is newest live
show and i was just like
that's not right surely but i watched it
and i'm like [ __ ] is this from this year
that's from like six months ago
um the one thing i was going to say
though about the movies and the cinema
releases
we're definitely seeing you know that
back in the day you did the cinema
release six months later after after it
lose the cinema six months then you get
on video or dvd
and then about a year after that
you'd get it on tv
yeah
that link seems to have been broken now
that doesn't that's not a thing anymore
is it really this because nobody buys
dvds anymore
um i keep buying the marvel movies
because i've got all of them and i want
the set
so i keep buying marvel dvds and the
wife's just like why
why have you done that i'm like because
i want it because they're cheap
they are pissed they are cheap um
but it's going to be on disney plus
within six months it just is
i mean mulan was on
uh came out on disney plus and i really
wanted to watch that the live action
move and i really thought it looked good
um it came on it was 20 pound
for eight weeks and then it was free on
disney plus
and i'm like
well i'll just wait eight weeks and they
actually told us how long it was going
to be until it came on disney plus it
was it was like november 12th it will be
on disney plus normal i'm like well
that's great that's a couple i'll just
wait
at the same time
yeah so i mean do you think that's
that's going to be the way it is then in
future that
which i think will be a death nail in
the cinemas because if people know it's
only it's going to be on disney plus in
a couple of months
well for me okay so the reason i didn't
plunk down immediately for mulan was
my god there's so much other crap on all
these streaming services i've got i
might as well catch up with something
else because i won't notice until disney
plus starts pimping it out for free
you know i mean i've got oh my god dude
it's just
i think at that point time was catching
up on shit's creek
you know when
yes when we move on
oh let me just you know binge watch all
five seasons of that and then by the
time i'm done with that then mulan will
be out so even though these big
blockbusters are getting scheduled into
these streaming services well dude i am
so backed up i mean it took me six
months just to go through and binge
watch all of star trek all of it
it was just an episode after it so i see
it as like okay yeah that gets inserted
into my queue here
you know yeah
and it's like oh only eight weeks oh
that's you know 40 episodes of star trek
see i'm i'm similar but what i do
instead of instead of sort of moving
gaps around i because i i subscribe to
netflix um
sometimes prime at the moment i've got
disney plus i also
have
brick box sometimes i have shutter
sometimes for horror movies
um but what i tend to do is i turn yeah
shadow's a good one but um i tend to
have like one or two and then i'll
storm whatever's on that platform and go
for it go for it go through it until
i've cleared through that backlog
stop it and then move to another one and
then go through that for a month or two
and then like keep cycling through them
um because yeah i'm i'm not keen on on
paying multiple subscriptions if i'm not
going to use them but
i think part of me wonders sometimes
because you remember there was the big
um we have the issue with with sort of
um sky tv over over here i'm not sure if
it was the same in the states but part
of the reason that torrenting became so
big is that sky became broken up into so
many different packages and people just
frankly didn't want to have all of these
different add-ons and packages so
torrenting became huge because people
were almost being um sort of locked off
content by by finance um and i feel at
the moment particularly with there being
more and more and more different
streaming platforms all with their own
exclusives and you know it used to be
very much you've got netflix and netflix
has got everything you know that's how
it was when it came out correct
you know now you know it's it's got
20 of stuff but the other 80 is on you
know maybe five or six different things
i'm wondering if maybe we'll see like a
return to or an alternative to
torrenting or something become popular
because eventually people just get sick
of paying for
loads of different subscription services
because it's quite expensive it's 10
pounder you know it's like it's i think
was it 12 pound now for netflix 11.99 i
think yeah
disney plus is still cheap much cheaper
but that's on purpose that won't be
forever as soon as disney plus get
enough subscribers they'll they'll start
beefing up that cost so we have 7.99 at
the moment so
um i've got apple tv because i've got an
apple phone so it's free but i keep
forgetting i've got it
um so i've got that that jason momoa
series where they're all blind i really
want to watch that
i could
yeah exactly
i'm so blind i keep it
by the time i get around to watching it
um the only thing was i watched there's
a tom hanks war movie greyhound that was
on apple oh yeah i love
tom hankson now that greyhound was
supposed to go to the cinema yes it was
yep
i thought if that was covered or
something else that caused it but apple
just paid for it
yeah so um apple gave them the money
well we'll we'll have it we'll put it
here so i think and they they just paid
a fortune to have it on their thing is
there big advertisement when apple plus
gets started started yeah i think
anyway
um
i i'm with you though i think i think
some at some point we're going to start
seeing ripping it
because it's
it's becoming it's starting to get
expensive now the only reason i say that
my sky tv i'm not sure why i've got it i
think they've been geniuses they don't
cost about twenty five pound one for me
to have sky tv
but they've thrown in netflix
so i get my netflix
they've got a big deal with netflix over
here that all of their packages come
with free netflix and that's not a deal
that's from now on
sort of thing so i'm thinking it's not
25 good then is it really for my sky tv
it's really 15 quid
yeah because you're playing 12.99 or
whatever for netflix anyway
and then the wife prefers it because we
can actually like record stuff because
she doesn't like going through apple and
you know the iplayer and stuff to watch
her eastenders and things she likes to
record things and have been waiting for
something so i was like okay then we'll
do that and so i think sky have been
very very clever with that
and netflix isn't very very clever as
well because it basically opens a
completely
new avenue for them but
i just i
my worry with this cinematic world is
though is that
what i i mentioned you stormy before he
died the oscars
right one of the things with the
eligibility for the oscars is you've got
to be shown in so many cinemas
so for so long sort of thing or you're
not eligible it's one of the reasons why
like netflix when they release a film
they'll just randomly put it on a bunch
of like backwater cinemas just just it's
about to do the eligibility right
will
the death nail be
when we see the oscars change their
rules
like they did with the music industry
about five years ago and they suddenly
said to be number one it's not about
record sales anymore we're going to
include downloads
and streaming
and then that's what's number one and we
saw this complete shift in the way the
number one the top 40 is now that like
ed sheeran can be like one two three
four five six seven eight and nine in
the top ten
for months because people it's actually
a reflection of what people are
listening to though rather than what
people actually buying
um
and the album chart is completely
irrelevant though basically you know
when we see the oscars change the rules
do you think that is gonna bad sign for
the cinemas
um
i don't know because most of the oscar
rules are driven by
uh studio pressures at least here in the
united states
um there was a major rewrite of the
oscar rules what two years ago because
of uh
all the the
uh all of the uh the above the line
slots were all white men
you know
and it's like um
and because of just
selection of material
a lot of black and other people of color
were just shut out of the awards
altogether and that was a major rewrite
and the rewrite was caused by outrage of
the studio studios look we've got all
these wonderful films with black actors
in it black actresses black filmmakers
why in the hell haven't they you know at
least got a nomination well the
nominations were expanded you know the
the uh
the uh the the things that were allowed
in that were previously pushed out were
allowed in and that was a major year but
that was pushed by the studios and the
studios like to have the uh the
opportunity to advertise their films as
oscar nominated actor
you know uh oscar nominated film or
oscar winning film this film got 17
oscar nominations they love that
advertising
and if if it's not for the bragging
rights no one cares about the oscars so
i think at least in the united states
it's a lot of it is ad
ad motivated
so whatever motivate the you know the
the the
uh the people to go buy it what however
the the oscars has to be as a marketing
venue that's how it'll change i think
so the rules will change at some point
then oh yeah
expense well they've been getting
less uh
well i mean i'm i'm not really want i
can't really comics i'm not a big
follower of the oscars but they have
been losing viewership steadily haven't
they
yeah
ticket sales
it does make one question you know
how
if they continue to to shed views like
that then
will that relevance
maintain do you know what i mean will
they will will it continue to be a badge
of honor if nobody's watching it
yeah it's true
they quit very quickly becoming
irrelevant yeah because maybe yeah i
mean i'm saying that completely biased
because i'm not really into it but um i
know some people who you know they they
make themselves food and tune in and
it's like a little bit of an event but i
mean all i know about it is with a
declining viewership that there has to
come a point where
you know it might matter to the industry
but if it does if they're using it as a
marketing tool and it doesn't matter to
delay person
then it loses impact
i think it was like uh i'm sorry go
ahead no no
i was gonna say it's like the uh khan
film festival you know it's all glitz
and glam earners actors and actresses
and no one cares except
the distributors
that buy these films to put in their
theaters or their streaming services or
what i mean it's a market just like the
sundance film festival is yeah it's a
market to get films into into
distribution
i think that's the old-fashioned thing
about like the critics as well and i
think that's becoming irrelevant as well
when you know they would have
these
barry norman was ours in the uk stormy
you won't know who that is but um you'd
have these know the critics and they'd
go and watch the movies and they would
tell us what was any good and what was
rubbish but i think with the advent of
youtube people don't listen to like
critics anymore they listen to youtube
channels like sidetrack
subscribe and um listen to what i tell
you to do
what should i tell you to watch um but
it seems to me that actually it's
there's so much opinion out there now
with this like things like maybe the
oscars are becoming less relevant and
critics professional critics are
becoming less relevant because
it's we've moved on
it's like you know um
i
think like oh man back in the day there
was a here in the united states we had
siskel and edward you know
gene cisco and rodrigo were and they
would um
generally if they both agreed on a movie
i would probably like it
but now yeah you know
things like rotten tomatoes there's a
lot more credibility in a rotten
tomatoes uh rating than there are any
even new york times you know the
criticism page no one cares well what'd
they say on rotten tomatoes let me get a
look and they'll they'll see a 99 rating
or whatever
let's go look at that or the you know
imdb ratings or they can have to be
right those things are much more uh
credible in the minds of viewers these
days than anything that is in written in
um
traditional studies
on the adverts on the posters and things
they started showing the rotten tomatoes
on the imdb
yeah so he knows the people's rating so
that's people voting isn't it
so i guess it's more democratic you know
because
not always times i i agreed with uh
roger ebert
you know or dean siskel
i always felt a lot of critics wrote
their own asses i have to admit
i i i've always worked in quite serious
jobs always my whole life i've always
wanted very you know quite serious jobs
so when i watch a movie i want it to be
stupid and ridiculous and stuff to blow
up and i don't want it to be oh this is
real and gritty that's why i don't want
that that's enough that's my day job i
don't really fancy that i want to see
faster and furious i don't want to see
impossible car stuff
and that's what i like you know and
saying i like it i like brain off
and popcorn
and just and just you know travel laugh
and
i was arguing with somebody about
stargate the other day i said on this
channel that stargate sgu was boring
and and i didn't like it so i've
actually been watching sgu again and i
can confirm
it's boring
um so
but it's because they took all like the
fun out of it and i that's why i liked
sg-1 it was
you know there was a bit of humor there
was a thing it was a bit silly it was a
bit you know there was there was
obviously brilliant storylines but it
was a bit there was a bit of sarcasm and
cheekiness and things all that was
sucked at this to you they were trying
to be too they were trying to be a bit
serious
i like my tv and i like my cinema to be
a bit like that so if a film wins best
oscar uh best movie the oscars sort of
thing i'm like i ain't watching it
and i know it's coming i'm not watching
it
so that is actually like i will go
through and check what's won the oscars
and what's one's best special effects
i'll watch that
but then whatever wins best movie
i ain't watching i was always you know
for stargate universe is always trying
to figure out you know is who's going to
get shanked first you know rush or young
you know
it was not like oh we're all going to
die because we haven't got to the start
to fill up the tanks full of energy no
it's is rush the one that's going to get
shanked
where's colonel young colonel young
maybe deserves a shanking but rush i
know deserves a shame thing so it's like
that was the the drama for me is like
who's going to get the knife first
my opinion on stargate sgu by the way is
an unpopular opinion
and i think he's corrected a great deal
um but i watched the first three
episodes recently and i actually really
enjoyed them but by the third episode
i'm already going yeah i can see where
this is going good night because no one
got shanked i mean three episodes i
think rush you know and then of course
he has his math cave that no one knew
about and he takes everybody well here's
the formula
i do like robert carlisle as an actor
he's tremendous are fantastic
the thing about sgu though the acting
phenomenal does the effects phenomenal
absolutely beautiful but it's too
limiting
they put themselves on a broken ship and
they're just like in the middle of
nowhere
anyway oh it's a bit like deep space
nine boring until the defiant came into
it
and that millennium falcon was also a
broken ship
i just said
i think you can have fun with broken
ships but it's about it's about coming
up with the um
coming up with sort of relevant
storylines that hook into it you know i
don't know
i just i i just don't know why has that
kind of hate in his heart
yeah i have i have hate in my heart i'm
sorry
um no i i didn't i didn't hate the show
i never hated the show i just i thought
it was a bit too slow for me that's all
no shaking
that's my thinking and there was just
too slow
so everyone that keeps going on at me
about why i hate sgu i don't hate sgu
it's just a bit slow and sg-1 is my i'm
going to say something very
controversial here i think sg1 is better
than star trek
um i think it's better than all of the
star trek
it's actually my favorite show can you
put my my panel on the other side of
spencer so i can get far away from that
opinion
i love it
sg-1 was my it was my show i mean i
think it's even better than the next
generation and next generation was like
my first love it was like you know that
that was my like my that first crush of
13 years old started next generation i
absolutely adore that channel so spencer
i guess i'm going to be uh taking all
the stray bullets that misses jamie for
you so
dave for next you don't like
and i'm still a trekkie i still love
star trek i just think sg1 edges it just
a little bit
hey brings
different strokes to different folks
yeah always say you know
exactly you've got your you know you've
got your star trek favorites your your
star gate favorites your babylon five
favorites yeah you know
firefly favorites five flights yeah yeah
ever made
it was
a perfect tv show
i miss it so
okay i think we've got that cover guys
and we're hitting the hour mark which i
think is a beautiful place to start but
just just really quickly
cinemas dead in the water or are they
just gonna have to change
i think if there's anything
any one singular reason while they will
always be
cinemas
it'll be the rocky horror picture show
mark might have to make that connection
for me what
why do you have a picture show i know i
know what you mean i was like
you know no one's going to throw rice
and toast in their own house at midnight
on a friday or saturday
no one's gonna have a hundred kids
running around in their underwear in
their house
so if there's any
any
uh
thing that's gonna survive for cinemas
it'll be the rocky horror picture show
because you want people to find by
themselves
my cinema emails me um every week so
i've got i've got that direct debit and
they said what film would you like to
watch predator
and there are no foods i was watching
put predator on
just and then like i think oh anything
else yeah maybe die hard put up i want
to see like classic movies put on there
i want i've never seen predator at the
cinema
i really want to and i would pay good
money for it
and i don't make a new predator i don't
want to see a new predator [ __ ] i want
to see go to the job or at the cinema
do it can we uh take a hot minute to
discuss new stuff coming up in the
cinema
let's just have a quick spence what do
you think on the final question mate
before and then we will yeah well let's
talk about what we're excited about
i mean i would be i would be sad to see
the back of cinemas i think um
yeah i mean as as long as like i said
earlier as long as directors keep
pushing their artistic vision and
keeping it off of streaming services
there will always be a need to go to the
cinema um no matter you know whether the
amount of cinephiles out there go down
or go up whatever there'll always be at
least a reason there that and rocky
horror um but yeah i mean if the
boundaries do continue to blur and you
know these studios keep releasing stuff
more and more and more
yeah it's going to be tough there still
will be cinemas but will there be as
many
i shudder to think
yeah so come on what we looking forward
to we're coming up to the christmas
months right a few big films coming out
well and this is a mishmash of uh stuff
that is going to be cinema uh directed
to the cinema and someone's going to be
directed to streams you know uh dune
is coming up october 1 here in the
united states matrix 4 was announced
that looks good as well i actually i did
put the advert on the channel
yeah yeah so looks so good
um
the sequel to blade runner 2049 was a
green lit this last week not sure when
it's coming out but there's another one
coming our way don't know who's going to
be in watch that what's 20 49 so um
avatar 20 is the next avatar is coming
out next year early i think
uh in terms of uh
yeah yeah
these are these these mysterious avatar
films that have been being worked on for
years and years and we haven't seen the
light of day yet yeah avatar two and
three is in post-production avatar four
and five is currently filming
wow
uh the foundation series is coming to
apple tv
so what is
the foundation series because me and
spencer both went then aren't you
talking about you can't you've got to be
kidding you
really okay i don't know what you're
talking about uh back in the uh
40s
1942 i think it was uh isaac asimov
wrote a book called the foundation
and the foundation is a uh it was a
story about this uh mathematician
philosopher
that
could predict how the future of
civilization was going to collapse
and so he rigged
events in such a way
that it collapsed his way it could you
know he he came up with a formula
to steer
civilization through the least violent
and least amount of suffering
and it it spawned
four books five books
uh yeah foundation along with irobot was
some of isaac asimov's most popular
stuff and it's coming to apple tv oh
thank god next week
uh excuse
and i would say that um concerning uh
football as you guys call it
i started watching
i started watching a dan lasso on apple
plus
and it i think it makes a lot of
americans fall and fall in love with uh
soccer excuse me football football
football yeah i think i i love that show
i've i've been watching that i do like
that [ __ ] one film you didn't mention
that's coming out at christmas obviously
we've got top gun too
which i i think will be very good unless
less um
i i imagine there'll be less oiled up
netball games
but um you never
which really is going to be kickstart in
the next
um you know then the next phase um and
actually watched sanctuary yesterday
gotta watch it guys it's it's it's a
phenomenal movie it's really really good
um it's got everything
classic about marvel
um it follows the formula that they
always follow um
but then it's got some really amazing
martial arts and it really amazing
special effects uh
phenomenal movie and michelle joe's in
it and she's phenomenal and everything
and absolutely stunning and the way she
moves
for a grandma
god damn she's sexy but um
i'm from star trek discovery so i love
her too for that
but i mean i think the eternals movie is
looking really exciting i'm really
really looking forward to that
so
unless there's anything else you guys
want to add
strange new world coming up strange new
worlds on netflix the new uh hawkeye
series coming up yep
yes
there is a lot of really good shows
coming up on all the streaming services
and the theaters
in this next most definitely there's a
couple of good netflix films coming out
actually as well um
they have old guard 2 is going to be in
production in the new year um there's
uh
oh there's a lot of films that are
coming out soon i really like looking
and i forgot what it was so we'll move
on but yeah i think there's they tend to
have one big film netflix at christmas
sort of time don't they and uh uh one
thing last thing i want to pitch is the
wheel of time coming from uh prime
amazon prime
yeah of course there's the new uh
uh
tolkien trilogies coming out also from
amazon
that series must cost a fortune you know
talking about quality and
production cost oh god it's well is it
just the rights cost a quarter billion
dollars or something like that
yeah of course i'm gonna watch it but i
mean he can afford it but he's just
gonna afford it yeah um that's just
basically one penis rocket to him that's
just one penis rocket that's right
so penis rocket
the seal moralian on film
i'll go slow morally and hopefully
so at least in that meme that was in
bezos and um dr evil next to each other
anyway both bald
both want to take over the world
both
oh and and
one more thing we gotta mention in terms
of movies kinda uh then the new james
bond daniel craig
it's going to be the longest james bond
movie is it real
wow um yeah it's got the longest
cinematic run
um and runtime um and that is phenomenal
to me because a lot of james bond films
feel really long
and you know so i really like scene
royale because it wasn't long
um and uh i'm i'm gonna be controversial
again though i'm not a big fan of james
bond movies
i think daniel craig is probably my
favorite james bond because it was more
grittier it was less flashier space tech
i mean moon wrecker really
really i mean i like
this time jaws flying in space no
roger mall though he was a cheeky james
bond
in karachi
for me
the first film with the new bond is
always the best one goldeneye best james
bond film
um casino royale
is the best one of all them for me
they're all the most enjoyable anyway
the first one always seems to be the
best one the first one in the last one
and then they all seem to get a bit
wobbly in between but um perspective was
good it was just a bit drawn out i just
felt it was a bit you could go and have
a makes up a cup of tea come back you
would have missed anything i found that
with quantum of solace to be honest
quantum massage was stupid actually yeah
and that felt like an old-fashioned bond
movie to me do you know we remember
it's an observatory or something up in
the andes and that's why they filmed it
and it blew up at the end and it looked
like they've blown up a model and it was
like
am i watching a 1990s james bond film
what the hell the the the premise i
understand you know it's like water i
mean here yeah
true as well foreign yeah here in
california you know it's oh it's bad man
i mean it is really bad
and uh you know
right now the sequoia national forest
the home into the world's biggest trees
it's on fire today because of our
drought it is bad
and so i get you know
and there's companies here in california
that is buying up water rights like
crazy
now one company they they sell primarily
pistachios
but the farmland they really buy it for
the water right it's not necessarily for
the smashes they sell this pistachios to
earn money to buy more water rights here
in california and then it's it's so i'll
get
quantum solus i understand the acting
and the
no i thought it was actually one of the
most interesting plots it's just a
bright film yeah
how long you think it's going to be so
we have to build a a pipe work
across from scotland
across greenland to california across
canada to california
so you can have some of our walks just
because we've got
loads
i remember we were chatting in the one
storm and you were saying about how this
storms fire and i was looking at the
window going it doesn't stop raining for
three weeks
in summer it was like july just rained
yeah i mean i'd you know i did a uh
a little film on sideworks you know the
myth of raking california
you know someone suggested well the
president trump suggested only we got to
do to fix the fire problem in california
is rake the forest well most of
california's desert and the desert's on
fire too it's not renting the forest
it's lack of water and climate change
unfortunately
yeah most definitely all right guys
thank you so much for joining us it's a
really interesting debate thank you for
having me topic yeah over the next few
years we're gonna have to deal with the
changing
way we watch our tv and watch our media
isn't it and it's gonna keep changing
and us all farts not you spencer or soul
farts like me me and stormy i still
trying to figure it out but i feel like
stormy's a little smarter on the uh on
the media than me
i still can't quite figure out how um
whatsapp works
so i think i'm in trouble
and um and i've got a youtube channel
that i have no idea how it works so
i'm a bit i'm a bit of an old father
when it comes to these things but no
seriously guys thank you so much for
joining us
say goodbye stormy
goodbye stormy
defense
fence
huh
hey i'm gonna know that spence
[Music]
do you know the main thing about this
it's our second live stream
and spencer's still able to sit in his
chair
i know i had a big cup of coffee instead
of a big glass of wine two streams in a
row
i know
did you get a kid after this or
something yeah i've cinnamon
started sweating already
[Laughter]
good night guys
peace
[Music]
you